>> We are thrilled to welcome you to the
second-annual online conference for educators.
Our session today, Social Media and Social
Studies, Engaging Students in Their Medium.
I would like to introduce our presenters.
Dr. Peggy O'Neill-Jones directs the
Metropolitan State University of Denver Library
of Congress Teaching with
Primary Sources Regional Program.
Publications include technology
integration, linking the learner to learning,
and from corn chips took garbology,
the dynamics of historical inquiry.
Peggy researches and presents nationally
and internationally about the connections
between emerging social media learning.
Kelly Jones-Wagy is a social studies teacher
at Overland High School in Aurora, Colorado,
and an affiliate faculty member at
Metropolitan State University of Denver.
Kelly has presented locally
and nationally about how
to integrate technology into
the secondary classroom.
Peggy and Kelly, welcome and take it away.
>> Thank you.
>> And Kelly and I are excited to share what
we have figured out and learned what we hope
to learn from you with using
social media with social studies.
Today's objectives are listed on the screen, and
I won't read through those, but you can go back
and read those, as well as
they're listed in our Google Doc.
We have a back channel, which is a
Google document that you could use to --
we'll ask you to type your name, your grade
level, and we're you're from, so at any point,
and now, or anytime during the session or even
afterwards, you can just go in and type some
of the -- your name, your grade
level and where you're from.
Okay, so let's get started.
So one thing is, we want to
get an idea of the social media
that if you're using it, the
type that you use already.
Okay, so I see blogs.
So none with students but Facebook
for personal use you're okay.
Google Maps.
Oh, yeah. Geography.
Oh, I'd like to learn more
about how you use that, as well,
and Google Maps with primary sources.
Perfect. We're going to do a Twitter
activity today, and I will be so interested
to get everyone's reaction with the
way we said and the way you use it.
Survey Monkey.
Perfect okay.
Instagram, okay.
LinkedIn. That's interesting.
I want to hear more, either
in the chat or the Google talk
about how you use LinkedIn with your students.
So why use social media?
Well, there's an engagement
factor with social media.
Engaging the students where
they are on social media.
No doubt there.
We'll probably pull off their phones and
jump on their platform that they're using,
and to get them to where you need them
to be, which is the learning target.
The other part about social media is
using social media for expression.
So using social media is the format
for them to express their knowledge
or their understanding of a concept or topic.
So we talk about social media,
there's reasons to use that.
Of course, many reasons.
Instant communication, it's
time and geography independent,
so that your activity doesn't just
have to happen in your classroom.
It can happen in different places.
It encourages conversation,
and you all know that.
Would you have different types of
students, the ones that raise their hands
and answer immediately and
monopolize the conversation,
as the ones that are very thoughtful.
They're just not out there all the time.
It is a different or different channel
by which to allow students to talk.
And it also promotes a community,
a community of learning.
So one of the things that we wanted
to use was this conversation prism.
This, to Kelly and I, is what most teachers see
when we talk about, well,
let's use social media.
They see this big blast of social media
tools, and when you zoom in even more,
it's even more confusing,
overwhelming, and I feel like --
and you guys can express how you feel, but
when someone says, I'll let you social media
in the classroom, you know,
like, and you begin where?
So this is how Kelly and I,
how we try to make sense of it.
What we're going to do is examine the
ways in which you can use social media
and primary sources to engage
students in historical thinking.
So we're going to rethink the framework, and
social media, in the context of social studies.
So Kelly, is there anything you want to
add before I move on to our new framework?
>> So one of the things, and we had
this conversation several times,
is that when we're talking about social
media and the way that it's used,
there are different ways in which you can
either bring social media into your classroom
as a source, or you could use it as a way for
the students to express what they understand.
And so most of what we're going to talk about
today is using social media for the students
to express their knowledge and their
learning, but there's also a way to bring it
into the classroom if you want to
as a resource in and of itself.
And so we'll kind of walk you
all through that as we go.
>> And just a reminder, Kelly is a
high school social studies teacher.
So she's in the trenches with this,
and she also uses social media.
So this is the way we try to make sense of it,
and let's see if this helps
you make sense of it.
There are three concepts that we're
looking at to distinguish the media type,
the expression form and the social media tool.
When we talk about media type, we think
about the way you as teachers think about it.
That if we're trying to introduce a new concept,
let's connect it to something
people already know.
That they're already familiar with.
So we think about the media type
with text image, audio, and motion.
And if you think about primary
source media type,
that a primary source media type would
be newspaper articles, letters, journals,
manuscripts; I use primary source image,
photographs, political cartoons, audio,
music sound recordings, motion,
video, film, animation.
Then we think about the media type, so when
we build on this conceptual understanding,
the media type, text, image, audio, motion,
then we'll also think about the expression form.
That you can have a concise expression
or you can have an expansive expression,
and in all of these, and a traditional form,
you could have concise or expansive expression,
or in social media, the same thing.
Here's our big chart on how
we try to put this together.
So Kelly --
>> Yeah, so when we made the discussion
about really what this looks like,
and one thing as a teacher and, I
don't know about the rest of you,
but I always feel like people are adding
more and more to what I'm supposed
to do and how I'm supposed to do it.
And there came a point in which I was very
overwhelmed with how do I use the tools
that are available to me, and the same time,
how do I get the students to
engage in what we're doing?
And so, one of the ways that I decided
that I had to do this is that if I wanted
to bring social media into my
classroom, is that I had to make certain
that I was taking something off my plate at
the same time I was adding something else.
And so that's what this really became for
me, was making certain that if I was going
to use Twitter, I was going to
use it to replace something.
And so the idea was that I was going to
replace the idea of doing a brainstorm
where I had the students read through something
or look at an image and tell me what they saw,
and then we would write it all on the board, and
instead of doing that, I wanted to use Twitter
as a platform for students to brainstorm as they
were going through primary source activities.
And it gave me both a good thing in the
sense that I was able to get students
who don't normally anticipate participating.
I also got information that a may not have
gotten otherwise and allowed students to kind
of move through the process at their own pace.
But at the same time, you also kind of
have to monitor just a little bit more,
because they are using social
media in the process.
And there are some back channel ways in
which they're not as public with Twitter
that you can use, especially if you
have a younger population of students
or if Twitter is not something
that you're comfortable with.
There's a few back-channel social
media applications for it, as well.
The other thing I really had to kind of keep in
mind was what exactly did I want the students
to be able to do in this process?
And so, you can see the idea of a concise
response from the students is under Twitter,
because they're limited to14o characters.
I can't expect them to write a five-paragraph
essay in 140 characters, but I can,
if you take a look over on the right hand side
where it talks about the WordPress and the idea
of a blog replacing information, and that was
one of the big things for me is making sure
that I understood like what did I want
the students to do with the information
and how did I want them to
express their knowledge?
Instagram I used to replace
when students made posters.
Flickr can sometimes replace a gallery walk.
There's a few other ones in here
with VoiceThread and SoundCloud.
Ways to replace things like
pair shared or round robin.
Vine we'll go over little bit today,
and that can replace a jigsaw,
and then the other thing is the famous
PowerPoint presentation where students copy
and paste everything onto their PowerPoint
and stand up there and read it to the class,
it is all very exciting for us all.
But instead, I started having my students make
videos and then uploading them to YouTube,
and so that way, they were
standing there telling us what was
on their PowerPoint presentation.
Instead, they made a video, and
they presented it to us that way.
And so it was a much more engaging way to get
the students to express their knowledge in a way
that they had never been able to before.
And this is not, by any means,
and exhaustive list.
These are examples that we put together.
If you follow our list, our chart
along from left to right, for example,
the media would be text, and then as
Kelly said, Twitter is a short form,
a concise way to express, 140 characters,
and that could replace something
you traditionally do --
replace or enhance I should say, something
that you traditionally do in the classroom,
such as brainstorming, and then
when you follow it to the right,
that a blog is unlimited characters.
You could have a five-paragraph
essay or whatever you want,
and then it can be the expansive expression
of their knowledge or understanding.
I think the other thing I wanted
to make clear is that I never think
of social media as a better way to do it.
That if paper and pencil work,
they work and they work great.
The way that we try to take
social media into the --
and connect it with traditional instructional
strategies is that it could be another way
to enhance what you're already doing, to engage
students that you might otherwise not be able
to engage, and of course, they're going to love
it when you tell them to take out their phone
because we're going to have
a brainstorming activity.
So there is our trying to take this
big glob of social media and put it
into a framework that makes sense for teachers.
So now, we're going to go to
instructional strategies and social media.
Kelly.
>> And I'm going to go through one
of the things about social media,
is originally, when I started using it.
-- I really used it is kind of look
at the amazing thing that I found,
and I had really no idea what
I wanted the students to do.
It was more than like a bell and whistle
than an actual instructional strategy
when I first are using social
media, and I realize,
I started getting more and
more social media tools.
And the students really never became experts
in any of them, and I wasn't entirely certain
if they were really getting out of each
lesson what I needed them to get out of it.
And so one of the things that I
wanted to make clear was that I had
to have an ultimate goal for the lesson.
It wasn't just about using
the social media anymore.
It was about very specifically what was my goal
for the lesson and how do I want my students
to be able to express their knowledge or their
understanding by the time that we were done?
Was this a short one where they
could express things quickly?
Was this something that I needed
them to spend more time on?
Was this closer to a summative
assessment than a formative assessment?
And so what I really started boiling
down, because I got so overwhelmed
with so many social media tools,
I really started say, okay,
one of the things that are going to get me where
I need to go and get my students were they need
to go and engage them in a way that sometimes,
there are just some topics
that aren't that exciting.
And so I needed to make them a little
more exciting using social media.
And so I really wanted to go
through and kind of take a look
at the traditional instructional strategies.
If I wanted my students to brainstorm.
Okay, so we're going to use
Twitter to brainstorm.
Or, I wanted my students to
analyze a primary source,
and I wanted them to simply
look at what was there.
Then Twitter was a great
way for them to do that.
But if I wanted them to take a look at multiple
primary sources, and I really wanted them
to analyze the impact of that,
but I really needed to look
at a different social media tool
for them to be able to do that.
And so that's what it really came down to as far
as when I started rethinking the
traditional strategies, it was what strategy
and what tool is going to
serve my students the best?
>> We're going to try primary
source analysis using twitter.
So this is, again, using a familiar framework
or a familiar concept and then take it
over to the social media realm, and on the
screen is the primary source analysis tool
from the Library of Congress, where you
have students look at a primary source
and they observe, they reflect,
and they question.
What we're going to try is to do
the observation part with twitter,
and Kelly will explain a little bit
more about the activity in a minute.
But one of the things that I wanted to mention
is that right now we don't have time to go
through the whole analysis activity, but one
of the things that I think about with Twitter,
in the very last presentations
with asking good questions,
they were talking about the challenges to have
students observe without jumping to inference.
Like all of us, when we see something,
we want to look at something
and then jump to the inference.
So in the observation phase,
observation can slow down that thinking
and make them make sure they look
and look carefully before they jump
to an inference of what that means.
And I think about twitter as a good tool
to do that with the 140-character limit.
You can confirm a lot that it might be
a good tool to slow down that thinking
and actually do that observation phase.
And the teacher analysis tool and guide are on
the Library of Congress on the teacher's page.
That's where you can find the activity dose or
the Library of Congress primary source analysis,
which by the way, on the Google
Doc, all of the links that does
to the things we are talking about,
they're all there, and you can get that.
So first let's try this, and Mike,
do you think we could put up a poll,
and let's find out how many
people are on Twitter.
There we go, oh look at,
look at these Twitter users.
My gosh.
>> That will make this a lot easier.
>> That, it's great.
And one of the reasons that we ask, and
I've been asked multiple times before
about using Twitter was that one of my
students don't have a Twitter account,
and there are times that you run into students
who either don't have it or they don't want it,
or their parents won't allow them to
have it, or your district blocks it
or something along those lines, and
other than the district blocking it,
any time that I use Twitter, I usually
have students work in groups or in partners
where at least one person has a Twitter
account, and almost never make them do this
by themselves unless it's an optional activity,
simply because I don't want a student to be left
out of an activity simply because
they don't have a social media account
or their parents won't allow them to.
So there are ways that I make sure that this
works for my students, and this is one of them.
So, okay, Mike, if you'll go
ahead and we'll go close the poll,
and we'll move on to -- Kelly,
go ahead and you can --
>> Yeah, and Kelly did a good job of
explaining one of the things about brainstorming
with my students in the idea of the
observation piece is that a lot of times,
they try and jump immediately to try and figure
out what something is, and so you really have
to train them to start looking first before
they start trying to jump to conclusions.
And so, for the students to be
able to take a look at an image,
and we are going to give you
guys the image in just a second,
and have you brainstorm your
observations, but not your inferences yet.
So the observation part is just being
able to write down the things that you see
in the photograph, and then you get to
the point of what could those things mean?
So this is how we're going to do it.
This is the primary source that we will
ask you to observe, and if you would,
if you're on Twitter, if you would type
your observation, and then use this hashtag.
It's the #LCteachconf, #LCteachconf.
On Twitter, and your observation,
and then include the pound sign,
and what that will do is create
a stream of observations.
So Keith, if you would put the link
to the Twitter, #LC hashtag feed,
then you all could -- I can't share my screen.
If you all go to that link on Twitter, then
you'll see as others type in their observations
on twitter and add that hashtag, then
you'll start to see a stream of observations
around this particular primary source.
Okay, so Leah just added
black and white photo, old.
So there's her observation.
June, woman standing perfect.
So now we're starting to get a -- the
traditional way might have been PostIt notes
that you might post around
the photo on the wall.
This can be the observation
using twitter, where we end up --
so Patricia, woman is posting
the billboard and smiling.
Okay, and these are all great observations.
You guys are so good.
Nobody has jumped to inference yet.
>> And one of the things, when you're
working with students is that there are a lot
of students who wouldn't naturally raise
their hand and put their information
and give what they see or their
observations or their inference.
They're not naturally those students that
will do that, but you'll find on Twitter
that students that normally are very outgoing
may sit back a little bit more on this one,
and the students who are much quieter may
jump in, and it's kind of fun to watch,
but you'll notice that the students who
are really outgoing also have pictures
on their Twitter feeds that they
may not want everybody to see.
So be careful of that, but it's also very
interesting, the information that you'll get
from students having to do with
just that they'll put information
out that they normally wouldn't, and you'll get
that very quiet student get making observations
that you normally would not
hear from them otherwise.
>> And Michelle added clothing is old
compared to now, but she likes the dress.
And I think the other thing, too,
is this Twitter feed that you --
this observation feed that you're
developing with all these observations
around this primary source, is something that
you could print out later so that, you know,
they all could see or it's something
that you go back and reference.
The same thing when you have
the observe/reflect.
You could possibly do reflect on Twitter.
I'm not sure about the questioning, because
that might be in a more expansive form rather
than concise, but you all would figure that out.
Okay, maybe, at this point,
before we go into strategies,
what about the Twitter activity doing a
primary source analysis using Twitter?
Oh, okay, so Hope has does you can use a tool
that collects all the Twitter feed, social fee?
Whatever, Hope, great suggestion,
and all of this is going to be
in the Google Doc, and that's great.
And Michelle agrees with hope
that Padlet allows that, as well.
And it may be an alternative
to schools who block Twitter.
So there you go, Michelle.
Michelle Pearson, who I know,
is a middle school teacher.
So I'm sure Michelle lives with
applications being blocked.
Yes, Hope, and twitter does require concise
information, and I really like that.
There's a skill to being concise, whether it's
image or video or text that cut in to the chase.
And Storify is great.
Yeah, that could -- yeah, oh, nice Hope, so
Twitter feed could be the new flashcards.
Okay, and there's a real-life skill
for kids using concise language.
Absolutely, Michelle.
And one of you had mentioned, and I can't
remember who it was on the Google Doc was
that one of your concerns was that students
needed to learn how to be responsible
on social media and things like that.
And this is actually kind of a fantastic way
for them to become a little bit more aware
of their digital footprint, and one of the most
interesting things I had is I had a student come
up to me and ask why I was trending on
Twitter for my students, because I use my own,
my name as a hashtag for the
students to be able to do this with.
So I have lots of students who will,
when we go through this, I'll have 30
or 40 students every day that
are using the same hashtag.
So I end up kind of trending among
my classes, which is kind of fun,
but then they get asked why they were
doing something, and they get I --
asked very odd questions like,
"What are you talking about?"
So it really allows them to have this
idea of exactly what gets left behind
in their digital footprint, when their friends
ask what they're doing tweeting my name
and what's happening?
And so it's a way for them to
understand just how quickly that spreads.
>> Okay, good job on the activity, you guys, you
are excellent students and excellent teachers.
So Kelly and I have a couple of other examples.
The links to these live are in the Google Doc,
but I will just show you
some screenshots of this.
So here's the instructional strategy,
another one, the primary source analysis.
The medium would be the image
and then a concise expression.
So again, rather than the Post-it notes,
this time, we would use Thing Link,
and I don't know if any of you have
used it, but I'm Thing Link, students,
or whoever's doing the observation can go
and, and when you look at, for example,
the little stars in the hearts,
would you click on those.
Well, there's an example, why the women are
coming out to the eastern half of the country.
So all of these observations that you made on
Twitter, well, here's another idea of doing it.
Putting a primary source up on something
like Thing Link and then having students go
around to the different parts of the
source and adding their observations.
Okay, Kelly.
>> And so one of the things
-- this one is not me.
The Vine that we have though
is absolutely adorable.
It's called six-second Shakespeare, and
unfortunately, we can't play it for you,
because it won't show up for you.
But there's the screenshot of it, and you can
see what this teacher has done is taken Vine,
which limit you eight seconds total,
and it's a great way to use summaries.
So if you want to summarize something, exactly
what something means and eight seconds or less,
this guy did a fantastic job of having the
students create little six seconds Shakespeares.
They have to be able to summarize
an entire Shakespeare play in six,
and he's got these cute little stick
figure drawings and everything else.
I mean, it's fairly simple.
Everybody, you know, they're
happy and then they all die,
because that's Shakespeare a lot of the time.
But it's a great way to go through
and use it as a summary tool.
So it would be fantastic if you had
multiple perspectives of something
and had students make a Vine regarding
different perspectives of the same event.
And so I've had my students --
I haven't done with Vine yet,
although it's on my list
of things to do next year.
Is I actually wanted to take the different
perspectives of the Sand Creek massacre,
because it happened here in Colorado, and
go through and create a six-second vine
about Sand Creek, but I have to be a little
careful about making sure it stays PG,
and Sand Creek is a little hard to do that with.
But it's one of the things that I want students
to be able compare the different perspectives,
and so Vine would be a great way
for students to go about doing that.
And Keith added the link to the YouTube,
which you can look at now or you could look
at later, the YouTube with the examples.
And then the other way to
do it if you're looking
for something slightly longer is Animoto.
They have about 30 seconds for
free, but you can go longer,
and we have the link up here, as well.
And this is one that I used in my economics
class for students to do it very quick,
30-second difference between economic systems.
And it's a very quick assignment,
but it was 30 seconds.
It took them probably about an
hour to put the videos together.
So we have a sample one for
you up here that we used
to compare these different economic systems.
And so it's a way for students to
express, again, this idea of summary.
And so it depends on what you want your
students to be of to get out of it.
When it comes to Animoto, you can sign up,
I believe, for an educator kind of sign in.
Oh, did some already put up there?
>> Patricia.
>> Okay, good.
Yeah --
>> And you get a little bit longer.
>> So you can have longer videos with
Animoto once you have an educator account,
and this one was make, actually, before you
they gave you that option, but you do have it.
So thank you.
>> And the next one.
>> And the next one is a WordPress, and
this is one of the things that I used
for my students as an exit ticket.
And the link is up there, and we
have a screenshot for you afterwards.
And so I come up with really complicated
questions for my students, because I can,
but I figured they would be able to, they would
really be able to tell me about more information
on a blog versus on Twitter, and so what I
asked them to do, I asked them to go through
and really answer them more in depth on a
WordPress, and the difference between this
and a regular exit ticket where they write
me a ticket -- paragraph and hand it to me,
is that everyone else in the class can see this,
and everyone else in the class
is expected to respond to this.
And so you can't get away with the
student who just doesn't want to do it.
And students put a lot more thought into
it when everybody is going to see it.
And so it's a way for them to also be
able to share ideas with each other.
But if they just wrote it on an exit
ticket, they'd never be able to do that.
They would never be able
to have that information
to hear what everybody else is thinking.
And sometimes that kind of groupthink is very
helpful when it comes to complicated questions.
And so it not only lets me know
what students are understanding,
but it also lets them build off of each other.
And so I liked the blogs for those purposes, of
them being able to build on each other's ideas,
which you can always do in a classroom
setting with them writing on a piece of paper.
They just can't all see it at the same time.
Okay, well, at this point, we would like to get
your ideas about how you might use social media
and primary sources to engage learners.
And Michelle said if your school
has Google Classroom set up
and a Google email Blog Spot is good.
Any ideas about an instructional strategy you
might change or replace with social media?
So June, she's like a Twitter in the classroom.
Great. Oh, and ideas for elementary students.
>> That is not my forte.
>> But I that we have --
>> But I bet there's people who
are better at that than I am.
>> Anyone out there who has ideas
for elementary school students.
I'm wondering if Google Expedition could
somehow work with the Library of Congress.
>> I don't know.
I have no idea.
>> I'd love the ideas, though.
Vine for annotated bib and other summaries, too.
Yeah, okay, and Michelle with Thing
Link and Animoto for elementary.
So there's an idea for elementary.
And Kid Blog.
Diane has Kid Blog for elementary.
These are just great ideas, and we're going to
assemble all of these again in the Google Doc,
so that you all have a nice take
away from this presentation.
"We Instagram to curate in our Makers Space."
Nice, Leah, at the elementary level.
So there we go.
Ask a question and this group will answer.
Parent interaction for community alert notice.
Oh, yeah, we can't forget the parents.
But talk about a way to bring parents
into the loop of what's going on.
Mystery Hang Out is great for elementary.
Okay. Oh, does the school need
to set up a Google classroom?
I can set up or I can set
up using my Google account.
Do you know school wise?
>> You know what, I don't know
because we don't use Google Classroom.
But I'm pretty sure you probably can.
Yeah, I can't imagine Google would lock
you out of it, even if the school is not.
And somebody answer for me.
So yes.
>> Michelle, she says you do
not need to use the classroom.
So thank you, Michelle.
And it may be a school by school decision.
Commonsensemedia.org has great
lessons on digital footprint.
Okay, Samantha.
Okay, so Leah, she can share
her twitter handle and email.
They have fifth-grade set up account,
and teachers give direction on topics.
So you guys are on list.
Love the Common Sense Media.
And Bridget, anxious to try some of these ideas.
And I also wanted to mention that there
is a way to carry on the conversation
in the TPS Teachers Network,
which is TPSteachersnetwork.org.
It is a social media network with the Library of
Congress to have teacher speaking with teachers.
It is a teacher/professional network, and please
feel free to join the network and join in.